we begin with breaking news out of
afghanistan where taliban forces now say
they've taken complete control of the
panshire valley the only region that had
been resisting their rule
battles have been raging for days in the
mountainous area north of the capital
kabul will it speak to charles stratford
joins us live from kabul charlie so the
taliban have made this claim before
haven't they only for it to be refuted
by the armed resistance what more can
you tell us
that's right darren but um this time it
does seem to be different this is an
official statement made by the official
spokesperson for the talibans abihullah
mujahid
he released a statement to a local tv
station a couple of hours ago i'll read
that statement out he said by the grace
of god the almighty and the support of
the nation final efforts for the full
security
of the nation have borne fruit and we
have fully captured the entire province
of panshire now this comes a few hours
after last night we had a facebook
statement made by the leader of the nrf
ahmed masood
as you say after days of fighting
massoud saying that he wanted to
negotiate with the taliban he wanted to
stop the fighting and talk we know that
there had been
days of failed negotiations and that's
what obviously sparked this battle so
this time it does seem to be different
also interestingly
has tweeted in the last few minutes we
understand he says that in that tweet
panchayat province was the last nest of
the enemy and it has been conquered
completely
so um yeah some very solid statements
being made by the taliban nothing
in response to that from the nrf we know
that communication out of the valley has
been very difficult in recent days um
all telecommunication has been blocked
by the taliban electricity too
but if indeed this is
fact then it is unequivocally a
historical moment
for the taliban because of course they
never managed to control that valley
uh ever and or of course did the soviets
during the 1980s
and it seems increasingly likely that
despite
some very ardent statements that have
been made in the last few days by the
nrf that they will continue to resist
that this time it may all be over and of
course there are huge concerns for
what's estimated to be 150 to 200 000
civilians living inside the panshir
valley mainly of the ethnic tajik
community in afghanistan a community
that represents about a quarter of the
population
um of course there have been big
questions about how
the taliban will form a new government
with these uh with this fighting going
on in the panchayat valley
now if this is over
one would think that it gives them a
better chance of finally
releasing some more solid information at
least on what this government could look
like but of course it's going to have to
include if they stick to their promises
the taliban that is it will have to
include representatives
from the tajik community it being so
large
so
it has been a momentous uh few days
certainly in in the panshir valley um
it's been very difficult to get any
clear information as to what exactly has
happened
but if the statement is true and it is
all over up there to say huge concerns
for civilian casualties the future of um
the the the leadership there as well
it's it's also important to say who
knows the fate of ahmed masood when you
have a statement describing um
by
mujahid saying that this was the last
nest of the enemy there are questions
going to be over the fate of masood
himself
and
you know
how much role he's going to have
in participating in any dialogue in
informing this government
so yeah if indeed true a historical
moment for the taliban but some grave
concerns about civilians and the
political future of somebody like ahmed
massoud who commands so much respect
amongst a huge number of this country's
population all right charlie stratford
live for us there in kabul charlie thank
you for that